John Wick chapter 4 might just be the
biggest and best Wick yet but as the old
saying goes you can't make an epic
action movie without cutting some heads
open we'll let Keanu Reeves explain
the John Wick franchise has been praised
for its use of practical effects and
Immaculate stunt work always pushing the
boundaries of what audiences expect with
each entry being bigger Bolder and
arguably better naturally this makes the
production of the movies a highly
choreographed Affair behind the scenes
on account of the intense moments of
hand-to-hand combat Snappy Gunplay and
jaw-dropping stunts unfortunately
accidents do happen and it seems as if
Keanu Reeves himself is responsible for
injuring A co-worker during the
production of John Wick chapter 4.
during an interview with comicbook.com
Reeves was asked about the number of
accidents that occurred during the
filming of a John Wick movie and he
prefaced his answer by describing the
conditions on set Reeves said everyone
is pretty tired but it's the best kind
of tired it's like you climbed a
mountain now you're resting like you
finished the game and you won Reeves
then mentioned two onset accidents that
sent stunt performers to the hospital in
terms of accidents I made a mistake once
and I cut a gentleman's head open so
that really sucked excuse my language
the other incident involved one of the
film's many car-based stunts Reeves
added one guy got hit by a car he was in
the car so he had to go to the hospital
but he was okay Reeves didn't provide
any context to the circumstances of
either incident and considering the
nature of the John Wick movies it could
have been anybody in chapter 4 who
happens to come up against the Fearsome
killer and chapter 4 is filled to the
brim with chaotic vehicular action in an
interview with Digital Trends stunt
coordinators Scott Rogers and Stephen
Dunleavy opened up about how difficult
it was to film The Paris Arc de Triomphe
sequence because of the amount of people
that needed to get hit with cars Roger
said we had to figure out how many
people can you hit with cars without
taking each one of them to the hospital
we want to do these spectacular stunts
but without losing sight of the reality
of it all safety is critical to making
these action sequences work and Reeves
told comicbook.com that the John Wick
team really cares for one another adding
all of this to say is some of the stuff
that we're doing you do have to take
care
oh yeah but it's it's great that
everyone is watching out for each other
can fight shoot and get hit for the sake
of cinematic Glory despite the risk of
accidents then again making something
great is hardly ever easy or without the
occasional misstep those in the stunt
industry love working on the John Wick
Flex as much as audiences enjoy watching
them continuing his chat with Digital
Trends chapter 4 stunt coordinator
Stephen Dunleavy described the franchise
as the Pinnacle of the stunt industry
and revealed that he turned down other
films to work on the latest offering
from director Chads to helski despite
the injuries that manifested on the film
set it's clear that the John Wick film's
value personal safety and pushing the
boundaries of stunt work as it stands
John Wick chapter 4 is the most
critically acclaimed film in the
franchise with many claiming it's one of
the best action films ever put to screen
clearly hard work does pay off
[Music]